i want to ask you briefly about uh the
the you know there
was all this talk and excitement about
uh you and your husband having this
netflix deal and it occurred to me
i've seen your i've actually followed
your husband
at the white house correspondents dinner
and followed him as a comedian and he is
a tough act to follow he's very funny
is there any chance that uh that your
husband would do a netflix stand-up
special himself
any chance that's coming in the future
you know i yeah i don't want to
close any options because who knows um
but i can
safely say that stand up will not be on
the higher ground
roster
[Laughter]
that would certainly be a be a strange
turn no one would see that coming
because i know you have to
be like oh a comedy special from the
obamas huh
yeah just your husband just prowling the
stage with a mic
and with like a cat suit on or
like chris rock or yeah you're something
red leather like eddie murphy
throwback stand that's something to
think about
please think about it i'll call ted
sarandos and see what
please tell him please tell him i just
you know just
just i'm glad i just i'm picturing it in
my mind and i'm laughing
uh it's making me really laugh